Générique
...
- Kathia Gilder: Bonjour à tous.
Ravie de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro
de "Parlement Hebdo".
On va revoir la semaine
sous le regard de notre invité.
- Alexandre Poussart: On accueille
Xavier Iacovelli.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes sénateur
des Hauts-de-Seine et président
du groupe RDPI au Sénat.
Vous êtes aussi candidat
à votre réélection aux prochaines
sénatoriales en septembre.
- Kathia Gilder: Pillages,
incendies, destructions,
affrontements: les violences
urbaines embrasent le pays depuis
la mort de Nahel, tué à Nanterre
pour un refus d'obtempérer.
Quelles réponses face au chaos et au
malaise des quartiers?
Cette semaine, l'Assemblée
nationale a dit oui
au partage de la valeur.
Le texte élargit les possibilités
de prime, mais aussi
d'intéressement
au sein des entreprises.
Une partie de la gauche regrette
la faible portée du projet.
La loi de programmation militaire
adoptée par les sénateurs.
Le texte donne un budget
de 413 milliards d'euros aux armées
pour faire face
aux nouvelles menaces.
Le président de la République
espère son adoption définitive
avant le 14 juillet.
- Alexandre Poussart: La mort
du jeune Nahel a fait réagir
les parlementaires.
La gauche demande un changement
de la loi de 2017,
qui facilite l'usage des armes
par les policiers.
L'exécutif tente
d'apaiser la situation.
- Après une seconde nuit
de violence, le président a été
appelé à réagir jeudi matin depuis
la cellule de crise du ministère
de l'Intérieur.
- Les dernières heures
auront été marquées par des scènes
de violence contre des commissariats
mais aussi des écoles
ou des mairies, et donc, au fond,
contre les institutions
et la République.
Celles-ci sont absolument
injustifiables.
C'est injustifiable.
- Emmanuel Macron avait voulu
la veille faire baisser la pression
en faisant part de son émotion face
au décès jugé "inacceptable
et inexcusable" de Nahel.
Tous les groupes de gauche
du Sénat pointent l'augmentation
de l'usage des armes à feu
par les policiers depuis 2017,
date de l'entrée en vigueur
d'une loi de Bernard Cazeneuve
assouplissant les règles
d'engagement par les forces
de l'ordre en cas de refus
d'obtempérer.
- Cette loi est manifestement
trop laxiste!
Elle a permis le développement
d'un sentiment d'impunité qui a
conduit hier à un drame.
Monsieur le ministre, si vous
voulez que le calme revienne,
et nous l'appelons de nos voeux,
il est temps de revenir
sur cette loi.
- Le ministre de l'Intérieur
qualifie cette demande
de récupération politique.
- Vous avez profité, c'est
affreux, de ce terrible drame pour
rappeler votre opposition à la loi
qu'avaient prise le président
Hollande et le Premier ministre
Cazeneuve dans des temps différents,
puisque c'était des temps
d'attentats terroristes.
- Pour la Première ministre,
les images de l'intervention
ne semblent pas respecter
le cadre de la loi.
- Les images choquantes diffusées
hier montrent une intervention
qui ne semble manifestement pas
conforme aux règles
de nos forces de l'ordre.
- La droite sénatoriale
se montre prudente sur ce sujet
où, traditionnellement,
les LR se placent
traditionnellement
du côté des forces de l'ordre.
- Je vois bien, notamment
à la gauche et l'extrême gauche,
qu'on tente de passer du procès
d'un policier au procès
de toute la police
ou bien d'un certain nombre
de doctrines de l'emploi des armes.
Je pense qu'on n'en est pas là.
- Le Rassemblement National a jugé
que c'était à la justice de
répondre à cette affaire, et non
au gouvernement de la commenter.
- Alexandre Poussart: La France
a connu plusieurs nuits
de violence,
des scènes de chaos et de pillage.
Vous craignez que cela dure
plusieurs semaines
comme lors des émeutes de 2005?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Bien sûr.
Je pense qu'il faut séparer
les deux événements.
Il y a à la fois ce drame
de mercredi matin, avec ce jeune
Nahel...
- Alexandre Poussart: Mardi matin.
- Xavier Iacovelli: Pardon.
On est tous parents et citoyens.
En plus, c'est mon département
et ma circonscription, celle de
Nanterre.
On ne peut qu'être choqué par
cette mort du jeune Nahel.
Mais cela doit amener à
une réponse claire de la justice.
La justice a été saisie très
rapidement.
Le policier a été mis en examen
pour violence...
Pour meurtre...
Pour assassinat, pardon...
Euh, non...
Pour homicide volontaire,
ce qui est quand même très rare.
Il a été incarcéré, tout de suite
après la garde à vue.
A la demande
du ministre de l'Intérieur,
il a été suspendu
administrativement.
On voit que la justice
fait son oeuvre
et qu'elle va vite.
C'est tant mieux.
Il y a cette partie,
il faut à la fois
respecter le deuil
de la famille,
respecter le temps de la justice,
et il faut apporter
des réponses claires.
Il y a d'autres événements,
qui ne sont pas directement liés
à cet événement,
qui sont les violences urbaines
et la dégradation du bien public.
- Kathia Gilder: On a l'impression
que la situation
est hors de contrôle.
- Xavier Iacovelli: C'est ça,
le problème.
Lorsque l'on s'attaque,
et je parle principalement de
mon département des Hauts-de-Seine,
à des écoles, à des collèges, au
mémorial de la déportation, qu'ils
ont dégradé, quand on brûle des
commerces, quand on brûle le
tribunal de proximité d'Asnières,
quand on brûle des tramways, qui
permettent aux salariés de
se rendre sur leur lieu de travail,
il y a des réponses à apporter.
On ne peut pas tolérer cela.
Je salue aujourd'hui la position
des élus des Hauts-de-Seine.
Je salue la position du maire
de Nanterre, qui, dès mardi soir,
a appelé au calme et à l'apaisement.
Il a dit que la justice,
ce n'était pas la rue,
ni la vengeance.
Je salue aussi la décision
du maire de Clamart, qui a mis en
place un couvre-feu pour permettre
d'apaiser la situation
dans sa ville.
- Alexandre Poussart: Les élus
locaux sont mobilisés, mais est-ce
que la réponse à cette situation,
c'est d'imposer l'état d'urgence?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Je ne sais pas
si nous devons le faire.
Je vois les décisions qui sont
prises à l'échelle locale,
notamment les couvre-feux.
C'est une restriction des libertés
dans un temps donné.
Cette possibilité est donnée
aux maires de le faire.
Je pense que c'est la bonne solution
pour apaiser la situation
et permettre aux forces de l'ordre
de reprendre le contrôle.
Cela permet que les biens publics
ne soient pas dégradés.
Il n'y aurait rien de pire que,
au-delà du matériel,
nous arrivions à un deuxième décès
lors de ces émeutes.
- Kathia Gilder: Ca passe aussi
peut-être par une reprise en main
du pays, avec l'affirmation
de plus de fermeté dans la réponse?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Je pense qu'il
n'y a pas de doute sur la fermeté
à la fois du gouvernement,
de l'exécutif, du président
de la République.
Il y a eu des mots d'apaisement
du ministre de l'Intérieur,
de la Première ministre,
du président de la République.
Ils ont eu des mots très clairs
sur l'apaisement et sur l'appel
au calme, et sur la nécessité de
respecter aussi le deuil
de la famille.
40.000 policiers et gendarmes
sont mobilisés partout sur
le territoire pour lutter contre
ces violences et ces dégradations.
Je pense que la main
ne tremble pas.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il y a
un malaise social de la jeunesse
dans ces quartiers.
On va écouter votre collègue
parlementaire des Hauts-de-Seine
sur ce point,
la députée écologiste
Sabrina Sebaihi.
- Les mots ne suffisent plus.
Ca fait des années qu'on dénonce
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui:
ces discriminations permanentes,
cette relation avec les quartiers
et les villes populaires,
les contrôles au faciès
permanents...
C'est certaines catégories
de personnes
qui subissent
des refus d'obtempérer.
On leur tire dessus.
Ce n'est pas tout le monde.
Ca fait des années
qu'on le dénonce.
C'est le résultat d'années
d'inaction.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce qu'il
y a eu de l'inaction de la part
des pouvoirs publics sur cette
question des banlieues, et
notamment pour Emmanuel Macron,
qui avait enterré le plan de
Jean-Louis Borloo
sur les banlieues?
Cette situation,
c'est aussi son échec?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Le plan
de Jean-Louis Borloo
a été pris en partie.
Un certain nombre de mesures sur
la politique de la ville
ont été adoptées.
C'est sous le gouvernement
d'Emmanuel Macron qu'on a doublé
les crédits de l'ANRU
pour permettre la rénovation urbaine
de nos quartiers,
pour avoir des immeubles sociaux
qui soit échelle humaine
et ne plus avoir
ces barres des années 70
qui pouvaient créer
un sentiment de délaissement
des pouvoirs publics.
On a remis des services publics
dans les quartiers.
Bien sûr qu'il y a
beaucoup à faire encore.
Je suis issu d'un quartier
populaire.
Je connais la nécessité
aujourd'hui de continuer
à investir et de remettre
des services publics.
Je ne suis pas sûr que c'est en
brûlant les services publics
que nous allons pouvoir en remettre.
J'appelle la députée de Nanterre,
qui a le mérite d'être arrivée
dans notre circonscription
récemment,
à nous soutenir et à soutenir,
comme le maire de Nanterre le fait,
les réinvestissements
dans les services publics,
et surtout l'appel à l'apaisement
et au calme.
- Kathia Gilder: Tout le monde
n'appelle pas forcément au calme.
Le député insoumis David Guiraud
a dit qu'il n'appelait pas au calme.
Il appelle à la justice.
Qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Je trouve
que c'est irresponsable.
C'est inconscient.
Quel est le but de La France
Insoumise?
C'est d'avoir le chaos
dans notre pays?
C'est d'avoir d'autres morts
dues à ces émeutes?
- Kathia Gilder: Vous pensez
que La France Insoumise jette
de l'huile sur le feu?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Depuis le début,
La France Insoumise
instrumentalise les événements
qu'il peut y avoir
dans notre pays,
depuis 2017.
Quand ils parlaient du fait que
tout ce qu'ils n'obtiendraient pas
dans les urnes,
ils l'obtiendraient dans la rue,
c'est aussi une façon
d'appeler à l'insurrection
systématique dans notre pays.
C'est aussi un moyen d'attiser.
Je ne mets pas sur le même plan
tous les élus de la NUPES.
Je mets ceux de LFI,
parfois ceux qui vivent
dans les beaux quartiers
parisiens
et ceux qui ne sont pas
directement confrontés
à la situation des émeutes
et de la violence.
Ce sont ceux qui habitent
dans les quartiers populaires qui
subissent.
Ce sont nos commerçants,
nos agents municipaux qui subissent
la violence et les dégradations.
- Alexandre Poussart: La mort du
jeune Nahel a relancé le débat sur
les interventions policières.
Est-ce qu'il faut changer la loi
de 2017,
qui facilitait l'usage des armes
par les policiers
en cas de légitime défense?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de tabou.
On ne doit pas avoir de totem,
ni de tabou sur l'utilisation des
armes.
Cette loi a été faite
sous le gouvernement Hollande
pour répondre à une nécessité,
notamment pour les actes terroristes
et sur la violence
qui en découlait.
Faisons en sorte de nous réunir.
Le Parlement est là pour ça.
Il est là pour débattre
sur ces sujets-là.
Ce que je ne veux pas,
c'est qu'on puisse légiférer
et prendre des décisions
sur l'urgence et sur l'émotion.
Encore une fois, ce n'est pas
parce que nous allons changer dans
la demi-heure ou le week-end une
législation que ça va
apaiser la situation.
Faisons en sorte de nous mettre
autour d'une table et que
le Parlement puisse travailler
sur cette question-là.
Je n'ai pas de doctrine sur cela.
Je n'ai pas de tabou à revoir
une loi qui pourrait évoluer.
Encore une fois,
ne légiférons pas sur l'émotion.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il faudrait
une commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur le refus
d'obtempérer?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Pourquoi pas.
Le Parlement est tout à fait apte
à faire des enquêtes.
C'est notre rôle aussi,
de contrôle du gouvernement
et des institutions.
Je ne suis pas contre
une enquête parlementaire.
Mais encore une fois,
ne faisons pas de la récupération.
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui,
nous sommes dans une période
où nous devons appeler au calme
et à l'apaisement.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce qu'il
faudrait réformer en profondeur
la police, comme le demande
notamment Jean-Luc Mélenchon?
- Xavier Iacovelli: C'est quoi,
une réforme en profondeur
de la police?
Je ne sais pas ce que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dit.
Il voulait désarmer la police.
Certains insoumis
disent que la police tue.
Je ne suis pas
sur cette ligne-là.
Si nous n'avions pas nos policiers
et gendarmes qui protègent les
crèches, les écoles, les collèges,
les mairies, qu'est-ce qui se
passerait?
Ce serait le chaos.
Est-ce que c'est ça, ce que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon cherche?
Ce n'est pas ce que je cherche.
Il y a un cadre légal qui est
clair et défini.
Ce qui s'est passé avec le jeune
Nahel, a priori, d'après les images
qui sont profondément choquantes,
cela sort du cadre
qui est défini par la loi.
La justice le confirmera.
Je le souhaite, en tout cas.
Je souhaite qu'il y ait
une réponse de la justice rapide.
Encore une fois, ce n'est pas
remettre en cause.
Là où je ne suis pas d'accord,
c'est qu'il y a une faute
très grave d'un policier.
Mais ce n'est pas la police qui est
remise en cause.
Ce n'est pas la police qui fait
des violences.
C'est ce policier, effectivement,
qui a tué le jeune Nahel.
- Kathia Gilder: On va passer
à un autre sujet, celui du partage
de la valeur en entreprise.
Un projet de loi a été
largement voté,
malgré les réserves
sur les bancs de la gauche.
- L'accord entre les partenaires
sociaux transposé dans la loi.
Objectif: étendre les dispositifs
de partage de la valeur
aux entreprises
entre 11 et 49 salariés.
Elles devront mettre en place
un mécanisme: participation,
intéressement ou prime,
si leur bénéfice net fiscal
est supérieur à 1%
de leur chiffre d'affaires
trois années consécutives.
- Si la France est
la deuxième nation d'Europe
en ce qui concerne
le partage de la valeur,
nous avons encore des marges
d'amélioration en la matière.
Nous pouvons être bien classés
au sein des nations européennes,
mais ce n'est pas une raison pour
ne pas chercher à faire mieux, à
faire plus et à faire davantage
pour la rémunération
et les compléments de rémunération
de nos salariés.
Quand la richesse est créée, qu'elle
soit encore mieux distribuée
au sein de ceux
qui ont contribué à la créer.
C'est tout le sens de l'accord signé
par les partenaires sociaux.
- Mais pendant les débats,
la gauche a fait entendre
une autre revendication:
la hausse des salaires.
- C'est la seule manière
de partager la valeur créée par tous
les salariés des entreprises.
Dans un contexte d'inflation
féroce, où le salaire réel diminue,
vous avez montré de quel
côté vous vous trouvez,
celui du patronat et du capital.
- Les insoumis et les communistes
ont voté contre le projet de loi.
Les socialistes ont voté pour.
Les Républicains et le
Rassemblement National
ont aussi soutenu le texte.
112 voix pour, 27 contre
et 8 abstentions.
- Kathia Gilder: Certains pensent
que ces primes vont remplacer
les hausses de salaires
dans les entreprises.
Le gouvernement assure que non.
Vous admettez que ce risque
existe.
- Xavier Iacovelli: Non, je ne dis
pas ça.
C'est un accord entre
les partenaires sociaux, entre
le patronat et les représentants
des salariés.
Ca date de février dernier.
On ne peut pas nous reprocher
de ne pas écouter les partenaires
sociaux et en même temps,
quand on transpose dans la loi
à la virgule près l'accord fait
entre les partenaires sociaux,
on nous le reproche quand même.
Quand l'entreprise crée de la
richesse et a des résultats
positifs, tout le monde participe
à cette répartition
de la richesse.
Il faut d'abord créer la richesse.
C'est tout le sens de ce partage
de la valeur.
Je trouve que c'est un bon accord.
Il n'a rien à voir avec
l'augmentation des salaires.
C'est un autre sujet.
Les partenaires sociaux sont
en train de travailler aussi dessus.
Le partage de la valeur, c'est
avant tout le partage
de la richesse de l'entreprise.
Quand l'entreprise crée de
la richesse, c'est normal de la
répartir.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas une préférence qui est
donnée à la prime temporaire par
rapport à une hausse de salaire
pérenne?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Ce
n'est pas le cas.
On a fait voter la prime temporaire
avec la prime Macron.
Ce sont tous ces dispositifs
qui permettent de supprimer des
charges pour permettre
aux entreprises de donner
un coup de pouce aux salariés.
Ca n'a rien à voir avec le partage
de la valeur.
Il y a l'intéressement
et la capacité de l'entreprise qui
fait des bénéfices à faire partager
cette richesse avec l'ensemble
de ses salariés.
C'est une demande
des partenaires sociaux.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a un débat
qui revenait sur l'hémicycle,
celui sur les superprofits.
Est-ce qu'il est plus juste
qu'une partie de ces superprofits
reviennent aussi aux consommateurs
que nous sommes tous,
via par exemple une taxe
sur les superprofits,
comme le demandent certains?
- Xavier Iacovelli: On a fait
cette taxe sur les énergéticiens.
Je préfère que cet argent aille
directement dans la poche des
salariés, que nous puissions
baisser les prix.
C'est tout ce que nous menons
aujourd'hui avec Bruno Le Maire
sur la question de l'inflation
et sur les prix des produits.
Je préfère cela plutôt que
d'encaisser des recettes
et une taxe supplémentaire qui se
noierait dans le budget de l'Etat.
Je préfère que l'on répartisse la
richesse des entreprises au niveau
des salariés plutôt que de créer
une énième taxe qui se noierait
dans le budget de l'Etat.
- Alexandre Poussart: Cela
permettrait de tourner la page
de la réforme des retraites et du
mécontentement social?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Je ne sais
pas.
Je pense qu'il y a des sujets
importants dans notre pays.
Il faut pouvoir avancer.
Il faut pouvoir continuer
à réformer pour améliorer
le quotidien de nos concitoyens.
Cette question du partage
de la valeur en fait partie.
Je salue la décision d'Olivier
Dussopt et du gouvernement
de pouvoir transposer ce texte
directement dans la loi.
- Alexandre Poussart: Direction le
Sénat.
Le projet de loi de programmation
militaire a été adopté,
en pleine guerre en Ukraine.
Il prévoit une hausse historique
du budget de nos armées:
413 milliards d'euros
de crédit entre 2024 et 2030.
Les sénateurs ont souhaité
que ce budget supplémentaire
soit débloqué plus vite
que ne le prévoit le gouvernement.
On écoute Bruno Retailleau,
président du groupe LR au Sénat.
- 413 milliards d'euros,
ce n'est pas rien.
C'est un vrai effort.
Simplement, nous voulons lever
un doute, lié à une incertitude
et à une facilité.
L'incertitude, ce sont les crédits
qui ne sont pas budgétés.
Ce n'est pas nous
qui l'avons pointé,
c'est le Haut Conseil
aux finances publiques.
Notre trajectoire a un mérite:
elle matérialise et concrétise
les 7,4 milliards
qui ne le sont pas.
Et le doute lié au reste,
c'est-à-dire à la facilité,
c'est que l'essentiel de l'effort
est reporté après 2027.
Et nous, on veut que ce soit
une progression qui soit linéaire.
Sinon, c'est le même effort,
les mêmes marches
que la LPM actuelle.
Parce que c'est maintenant,
la guerre.
C'est maintenant
qu'on doit faire l'effort.
C'est maintenant, l'inflation.
L'euro d'aujourd'hui
n'a pas la même valeur,
il vaut plus que l'euro de demain.
- Alexandre Poussart: La majorité
de droite sénatoriale souhaite
que cet effort budgétaire
pour nos armées
se fasse maintenant.
Ca paraît logique.
On est en pleine guerre
en Ukraine.
- Xavier Iacovelli: Je pense que
la majorité LR a compris qu'on
avait déjà mis des moyens
supplémentaires, notamment pour
répondre à la question
de la guerre en Ukraine.
Cette loi de programmation
militaire
de 413 milliards d'euros,
ce n'est pas une pacotille.
Ca va nous permettre d'avoir,
en plus d'être la première force
armée d'Europe en nombre d'hommes,
le plus gros budget européen
sur l'armée.
C'est une vraie ambition,
portée par le ministre Lecornu,
par le président de la République.
C'est un vrai progrès.
Je pense que c'était aussi
une attente forte de nos armées,
en termes de matériel, en termes
de réponse aussi sur
une revalorisation des pensions
pour nos militaires, pour
la protection aussi de leur famille.
Tout ça, ce sont des éléments
qui sont importants.
J'ai vu que les LR avaient proposé
7 milliards de dépenses
supplémentaires.
Je vois qu'il y a globalement
un consensus sur cette loi.
Je pense que nous aboutirons,
en commission mixte parlementaire,
à un accord.
Je ne doute pas que cette loi
de programmation militaire
sera validée définitivement.
- Kathia Gilder: Avant
le 14 juillet, comme le souhaite
Emmanuel Macron.
Cette loi pèse 413 milliards
d'euros.
Elle prévoit un saut technologique
pour les armées,
comme le dit
le ministre de la Défense,
et notamment la construction
d'un nouveau porte-avions.
Mais quand on regarde le niveau
de la dette française, qui atteint
plus de 3000 milliards d'euros,
est-ce que vous pouvez dire que la
France a encore les moyens
de sa défense?
Est-ce qu'elle ne voit pas un peu
grand, avec une dette pareille?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Je pense
que la situation géopolitique et
internationale, y compris aux
portes de l'Europe, nous démontre
que nous n'avons pas le choix.
Nous devons à la fois
nous protéger, avoir cette force de
dissuasion qui est importante dans
notre pays...
Nous devons trouver les moyens
de notre défense.
C'est bien aussi, de comparer.
Nos dépenses sociales.
C'est 30% du PIB.
Notre force de dissuasion
militaire, c'est 1,9%.
Nous continuons à avoir une
politique sociale très importante
dans notre pays, mais il est aussi
important que nous puissions
protéger les intérêts français
à l'extérieur, mais aussi
à l'intérieur, et que nous ayons
une armée conséquente et dotée.
Il faut qu'elle soit respectée
dans ces conditions.
C'est une demande forte
de nos militaires.
C'est une demande forte aussi
de nos territoires.
La situation internationale
nous pousse à avoir cette loi de
programmation militaire
ambitieuse.
- Alexandre Poussart: C'est
important, d'investir davantage
dans notre dissuasion nucléaire?
- Xavier Iacovelli: La dissuasion
nucléaire, la question
de l'innovation,
vous en avez parlé.
La question des drones,
la question de l'espace,
ce sont des éléments importants
pour la protection
des intérêts français.
Donc oui, c'est tout à fait
important.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
la France doit rester dans
le commandement militaire de l'OTAN?
- Xavier Iacovelli: Je le souhaite.
Il faut que nous restions.
Cette décision a été importante.
Il faut que nous continuions
à être présents.
La France fait partie
historiquement
du concert des nations.
Nous avons besoin de continuer
à oeuvrer dans ce sens.
- Kathia Gilder: On arrive
au terme de cette émission.
Juste avant, un petit coup d'oeil
sur le menu parlementaire
de la semaine prochaine.
- Alexandre Poussart: Mardi,
les sénateurs commenceront le débat
autour du projet de loi censé
réguler l'espace numérique.
Jeudi, la commission
d'enquête du Sénat
sur le Fonds Marianne
publiera son rapport,
tout comme la commission d'enquête
des sénateurs
sur le réseau social chinois
TikTok et sa stratégie
d'influence.
- Kathia Gilder: A l'Assemblée,
la réforme de la justice sera
au programme de la session
extraordinaire qui s'ouvre
ce lundi 3 juillet.
Le texte a déjà été voté
par le Sénat.
A suivre, mardi,
une audition de Bruno Le Maire,
auditionné sur la relance
de la filière nucléaire.
- Alexandre Poussart: Merci
d'avoir été notre invité.
Merci de nous avoir suivis.
- Kathia Gilder:
A la semaine prochaine.